feel very true to the to this show and
to this to the character so if I win
I'll bring your head to surface a
certain kisser one last time so what was
your initial reaction when you read your
last script I can say something I can
say I was I was very excited I'm very
happy for the way that my character is
gonna end up when Game of Thrones I got
introduced a little bit later in season
six so I honestly I was like why would
you introduce the character in season
six and then killing season seven or
beginning of season eight so I'm very
happy
I'm the man who kills Jamie Lannister
talk to me about your reaction when you
read the script for your final episode
um a wife I was I was really pleased
with that just look at me I mean I
thought they did an amazing job overall
with every with the whole with all
season but but with Jamie also just
really yeah it made sense and he it
wasn't was very in them feel very true
to the to this show and to this to the
character so wasn't happy
[Music]
[Applause]